let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
welcome everybody this is the Tony
Michaels and this is Gabe Sanchez and we
put together the best of the week from
the Tony Michaels podcast don't go
anywhere stay right here for the best of
the week Marjorie Taylor Green speaking
of speaking of white nationalists
um Marjorie Taylor green
she was at it at her Republican primary
debate it is it is worth watching here
let's let's go to it here I forget the
guy that they're the opponent's name
he's a republican he really puts her in
his in I think his name is Sean or Seth
yeah something like that I I don't know
he's a Republican and he's I mean he's
likely to be just as much of a sick of
fan to Trump as anyone else yeah but
here here is the example of how we draw
wedges in between these Republicans to
win the 2022 midterm this this right
here is the is the map and the blueprint
folks watch what he does and Democrats
need to keep doing this all over the
place to draw wedges between these
candidates uh to to Tamp down and to
suppress their vote that's right folks
we're all here because we have concerns
about the seat
see you bought defense contractor stock
before railing against profitable Wars
your words and actions are consistently
inconsistent no bill you've authored has
passed before before we watch the
Restless do you think she says the words
do not recall I'm almost I I almost
think that's like a like a recording
that she has that she's like I do not
recall I do not have an easy button
right right
she likes your mouth any move it's just
it's just like just pull the string on
the the dummy well I mean you know
you're what you're going to see here is
a bunch of lawyer talk this person is is
obviously uh and her attorneys obviously
think that she actually has some
criminal liability towards the
Insurrection to some degree otherwise
she wouldn't say some of the stuff she's
saying how she's saying it but listen to
what she says here and you have no
committee power to advocate for this
District without resorting to rhetoric
about Democrat Boogeyman Biden and the
Wolf left answer this can you tell us
one or two specific objectives that
affect our wallets that you can actually
pass and explain how you plan to get it
done without being guaranteed a
committee assignment well thank you and
I know you okay
safe to assume
she does not say I don't recall
I think she's gonna answer
but I wouldn't be surprised if she also
gives a non-answer well I mean this is
Marjorie Taylor green that we're talking
about she's gonna I mean here's the
thing he said don't mention like the
woke left in this I I have a feeling
throw it in there she may not say woke
left exactly but I I bet she throws
something in there that's like something
to the of the deep state or whatever the
[__] [__] that she tries to smear
all over there I guarantee she gives a
non-answer and tries to blame someone
else and she's she's totally she
you haven't seen this clip then you
haven't watched no no no because I I put
my uh my desk she says you're welcome
minus Robin says you're welcome donate
thank you for for pointing this clip out
I actually went and pulled it and posted
it on our podcast uh Twitter account for
everyone to see
um but Gabe Gabe haven't seen this yet
so let's listen and let's see what his
response is to uh to uh foot greens here
um her answer to his question media
Simon well thank you for that question
Seth and and I know you this is your
first time being a candidate as well so
I usually find out about stock trades
when I read them in the news just that's
what you have I signed an agreement with
our financial advisor that I don't know
anything about trades that are made she
doesn't recall Gabe she doesn't recall
she didn't say I don't recall
I always find out about them when
they're written by leftists like
Business Insider there it is there it is
there's leftist like business Business
Insider you bunch of [__] lessons so
so that means wait hold on so that means
she gets if you recall what she just
said she said she does not hear about
them until they're in the right in the
trades right
and then she she signed an agreement
which doesn't really mean anything in
terms of with her financial advisor now
what she's saying is she doesn't hear
about them until they're in leftist uh
articles like Business Insider which
means she's getting her trade
information from leftist articles right
in Publications right this answer is
[__] let's let's let's let's let's
listen to the rest of who it's um
diatrive here just like you're talking
about now here's what we have to do you
have to understand and remember
Democrats are in control in Washington
right now she's telling other people to
remember right right the person who
doesn't recall anything is telling other
people to remember all right so she
didn't say deep State she didn't say
woke love she said the Democrats are in
control so it sounds like she's gonna
blame them well we're not getting
anything done right absolutely right
well let's let's hear what she says
Republicans aren't getting anything done
even the Republicans on committees
aren't getting anything done and it's so
so now so now it's anyone who who's not
on a committee are the actual ones who
are getting things done right do you
notice that Democrats who are on
committees who are in control of
committees they're not getting anything
the Republicans who are actually on
committee Escape they're not getting
anything done or definitely it's the
only the only people like me who are not
on committees right who can't introduce
legislation into committees to make sure
they get to the house floor I can only
go to the house floor and [__] and
[__] and [__] in front of a microphone
and be a racist white nationalist piece
of [__] a manga King a mass shooter
enabler and then that's the only that's
the only voice that I have what a
bonehead let's let's listen to more of
the bone-handedry if they were you
wouldn't see the radical destruction of
America going on right now our wide open
borders we are having inflation out of
control and we are no longer energy
independent As Americans so what I look
forward to doing is we were never energy
independent let me ask you Gabe are you
energy independent do you have your own
energy like I mean if you're independent
is your energy uh
uh like me pert my body Yeah well yeah
she said Americans aren't energy
independent well I mean my body America
actually is my body needs to to need
sustenance you know so I have to have to
actually eat stuff so I'm not actually
I'm not independent it's not like my
body is a is a is a you know infinitely
going uh battery you know I'm not like
it's not like the Matrix where you plug
me in and boom boom I still have to have
nutrients to feed to create the fuel you
know and and energy
she wants Americans to be energy
independent not America right American
when have we ever been energy
independent I don't know this is
fossil fuels we have obviously Drilling
in in the United States but we certainly
import our stuff we have never been
energy independent complete energy
Independence would be we don't rely on
anyone else we've got sustainable energy
and actual Solutions and things that
don't require us to say oh [__] when all
this [__] thing burns up you mean the
finite resource so there's a good theory
out there it's called the the peanuts in
the room Theory have you ever heard this
Theory before so what is it a gallery
well well not exactly but it's a room
full if I gave you a room full that was
packed full like a bedroom sized room
full of peanuts yeah and I told you Gabe
that you could have all these peanuts
and you can eat as many as you want but
you can't take the shells out of the
room you can't take the shells out of
the room you cannot you can't remove the
shells you can de-shell the peanuts and
you can eat the peanuts but you can't
take the shells out of the room so how
how long do you think it'll take until
you're just tired of looking for peanuts
still in the Michelle how long do you
think it would take oh pretty quickly
right now here's the reason why we don't
want to be oil independent in this
country because that's really what she's
saying she's not saying energy
independent as we only produce our
energy here she's saying we only want to
buy oil that is American oil
which is [__] ridiculous because we
give Federal contracts to all kinds of
foreign companies to actually come here
and drip with the oil BP is not an
American company okay British British
Petroleum okay wait wait wait the same
British that America tried to you know
leave right we had a we had a war with
tyrannical government you know the
reason why we have to have our Second
Amendment rights Second Amendment to
fend off British Petroleum now the
reason the reason why we don't want to
be energy independent is exactly the
peanut shell Theory because if we
actually use up the entirety of our oil
reserves that we as America and our
nation owns eventually it'll be really
hard to look for it and we won't look
for it anymore it won't be cost
effective to look for it so what we do
is we actually buy buy crude oil do you
know what crude oil is they'd pump it
out of the ground and they they ship it
over here from other countries and we
buy it from them so we don't have to
actually use our finite resource which
makes us energy Independent by us not
drilling all of our oil Gabe it makes us
oil independent when we're not it seems
like it's like oil responsible right
well right because you don't want to if
you had a backup Supply let's say that
you had like um
um like a bunch of stuff in case
something goes wrong right like uh
you're like hey we've got this on a
reserve almost like an oil Reserve in
case
[__] hits the fan and we've got a we
gotta pull from the reserve to kind of
replenish our supply and maybe there's
an overseas kind of Crisis that might be
creating a shortage and we need to rely
on that if we use all our oil like
you're saying then we wouldn't have that
Reserve which means and then we're
paying out of the ass for someone else
to give us that's potentially shitty oil
that's got a bunch of sand and dirt in
it right is everything so what you're
what yeah what I'm saying is if we if we
take all of our finite resources whether
they be oil or anything else and we only
use them here and we and we mine them we
drill them we pump them and we suck them
out and we use them eventually we won't
look for them because it won't be cost
effective because there'll be too many
peanut shells in the room to look for
peanuts number one number two we won't
have peanuts anymore we will give up on
the room so we won't be energy
independent get the get you pull your
heads out of your asses it's almost like
hey Super Chat
uh it's almost one thank you it's almost
like
we need
renewable no energy no Gabe Gabe that is
that is that radical liberal socialist
I'm just saying
if there's a finite amount of resources
what you're saying is we interject
resources that aren't finite like what
like what could that possibly be I don't
know like uh Hydro power or or or air
right like wind solar you and your Kami
wind turbines I'm just saying like if we
look at the elements of the Earth right
Earth Wind Fire right land you know uh
right you want to start singing Earth
Wind and Fire yeah you know it I you
know then sing the song in September you
know anyway you have these elements and
you know if you've got Hydro related
energy resources you've got wind related
energy resources you've got solar you
know these seem to be like resources
that we have enough of that we can reuse
right we don't just use it and lose it
we are able actually to to renew these
resources on an ongoing basis you know
it's almost like they're infinite
they're not entirely infinite for some
but they seem like they're infinite for
the most part right
I I I believe I believe wind will keep
blowing rain will keep falling and the
sun will keep shining as long as long as
we don't drill the hell out of the earth
and cause it not to be that way um we
got another Super Chat in here donated
in the name of Baron von Schneider's
name thanks for driving donations I'm a
strong woman God supports not
threatening not threatened by and guess
what I carry Caitlin says thank you for
the super get
so let's let's listen I'm sorry to get a
sidetracked on um what what energy
Independence means let's listen to what
the bonehead is I love this paused face
though by the way I almost don't want to
play this now that her face just pause
this way you need to take a screen
campus and use it on one of our famous
thumbnails Let's uh let's continue here
back to the house I'll have great
committee assignments Kevin mccarthan
leadership of arguments to them I doubt
it to me and we look forward to holding
Democratic account of all the corruption
and horrible things they've done in our
country thank you okay let's give us
Seth a 30 cents to respond so do you
hear that Kevin McCarthy has promised
yeah if you need any other animation out
there and this is this is what I was
talking about when I said this is the
wedges that they are designing to draw
right if you have any other wedge that
you need to draw oh it is the Kevin
McCarthy Kevin McCarthy has promised
Marjorie Taylor green which means that
he's promised Madison cawthorne Lauren
Blue Bird he might even promise them
chair chairwoman ships who knows who
knows they've made me in charge of these
committees are you gonna go vote are you
gonna let Marjorie take their green be
the chairwoman of the economic Committee
of the Foreign Relations Committee are
you gonna do that huh huh well go vote
let's see what's it's his name Seth I
think he said yeah let's see what Seth
here is a rebuttal
that's too big an if uh voting for Mrs
Green is a Gamble and she's not
guaranteed a committee power
she's not even accountable for her own
tweets or her staffs we're still not
clear Who's acting on the district's
behalf now that there's another wedge to
draw between these Republicans have you
noticed this Gabe that they have taken a
lot of their official accounts like uh
and they they've they've kind of branded
them as press release account right
they've started to do that and it's
because of her and it's because of uh uh
Paul gozar and some of these others
because they want to blame their staff
right right they want to blame their
staff on any any tweets that they might
throw out there on their official
Congressional accounts and that's what
he's talking about here because this
idea that she doesn't have a Twitter
account because uh it's kind of
ridiculous she does have one she does
tweet she tweets all the time from this
Twitter account let's listen to what
Seth says so how can anyone expect her
to bring accountability to Washington
her only leadership trait right now is
rallying people against an enemy and
little to none of what she just said
encourages business in our district
or fights out of control inflation
so there you have it again what did I
say a non-answer she went in he was like
yo give me the actual policies that you
will pass if you are re-elected right I
want to know what you're doing I want
the people of your District to know
exactly what you are trying to do to
help them right there are issues at hand
what do you actually like what Solutions
are you offering and she goes in and
says well you know it's run by the
Democrats the house and the the hill and
we don't really have as much uh control
as we did once but once I'm re-elected
Uh Kevin McCarthy told me he's promised
me so just go to take me take my word
for it not word [__] two cents uh
take my word for it that when I get back
into that seat for this District
Kevin McCarthy's gonna put me on a on a
straight on a on a committee he's gonna
put me on many committees he's gonna put
on so many committees he's gonna be the
best committees ever right
anyway
uh what am I doing how am I doing I'm
good I just I just put a clip together
actually we could play the clip I just
put a clip together of uh
2018 Tucker Carlson in 2022 Tucker oh
really yeah that would be beautiful did
you did you post it on Twitter or I was
literally about to but I'll play it here
as a promoter oh my gosh exclusive
exclusive Gabe Sanchez
cut and clip where how are you going to
do this you're going to send me a link
are you going to no I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna put it on I'm just gonna put
it up here we're gonna do a live baby
we'll do it live do it live do it live
have you guys ever you guys probably
know that we're referring to the uh
um what what's what what uh Bill oh yeah
I I always just think of him
what does it mean to play it off what
what the [__] does that mean to play it
off it's like [__] it we'll do it live
we'll do it live we'll do it live that's
what we do here we do it live yeah okay
two hours a day am I playing this video
this is the one yeah this is this is
Tucker Carlson the flip flopper
well in the past two years the
Democratic party has outsourced much of
its political philosophy to the late
night TV shows they haven't closed the
think tanks here in DC but they don't
pay any attention
they pay attention to Saturday Night
Live it's not as funny as it used to be
but it does not knowing what the left
now believes here for example is their
final pitch for the 2018 midterms
Republicans
are disgusting some of them were even
wounded in Wars big surprise to hear
he's a congrats
Oh I thought it was a sound bite but
it's not you're seeing on the screen
though part of Saturday Night Live Texas
Congressional candidate Dan Crenshaw
lost an eye to an IED in Afghanistan on
Saturday actor Pete Davidson mocked him
as one of the quote really gross people
running for office this year he said
added I'm sorry I know he lost his eye
in war or whatever
yeah so that's their position and
they're not hiding it anymore useful for
you to know that's it for us tonight
we're out of time sadly that hour went
quick will we will be back every week
night 8 P.M the show that is the sworn
and sincere enemy of lying pompacity
smugness the more I think about it it
takes a lot of gall for eye patch McCain
to attack moms you'll worry about baby
formula as well
that's one of the most outrageous things
I think I've ever heard now that I'm
thinking about it why not just answer
the question why why do you tax what
does that tell you
so
example November very interesting 2018
Tucker Carlson goes on the defensive and
says oh Pete Davidson is is a is a
terrible person for making fun of Dan
Crenshaw the joke was he reminds him of
uh of uh uh a hit man from a porno that
was the joke right that that was that
was that was Pete Davis Pete Davidson
went through a list on Weekend Update
and was talking about different
candidates that were running for the
Republican Party in the primaries and
when Dan Crenshaw came up he said oh it
reminds me of a Hitman from a porno
that's what he said let's be fair here
let's be fair here he definitely did
look like a Hitman oh yeah number four
now I mean the joke isn't that far off I
mean
no you have uh Tucker Carlson getting
all butt hurt and saying that SNL is uh
is making him
uh making fun of him and then you get
Tucker Carlson 2022 where he's like oh
he's eye patch McCain so you know just
to go to show you that Tucker Carlos is
not who he says he is he doesn't believe
what you all think he believes in he
will say what he says because it's an
entertainment show it is not news and
once again Tucker Carlson flip-flops
more than I don't know Mitch McConnell
hmm surely Tucker Carlson doesn't have
flip-flopping views and I bet I would
almost bet that Chris Dan Crenshaw if
you looked at enough clip which I'm
going to have one right here
um also also doesn't have flip-flopping
views
um Dan Crenshaw seems to be very woke
these days uh as as Tucker Carlson would
say let's a lot of infighting yeah let's
listen there's some bad arguments too
people are saying well we can't put baby
formula on our shelves but we're sending
money to ukrainians and my response to
that is you know how much baby formula
you can buy with 40 billion dollars none
none because it's not a money issue it's
a manufacturing issue oh Dan Crenshaw
and your facts
you know I've always said what I've
always said about Dan Crenshaw
get get a [__] glass eye would you
please this is really done with the
iPads you trying to look cool you're
trying to look tough and I actually I'm
with Tucker here I actually think
eyepatch McCain is not it's not that bad
of a nickname I mean frankly if you know
if you're gonna if you're gonna break
away from Tucker and say is it is it
a great nickname but but I could see you
here on both sides right is just [__]
gross
um I mean Dan Crenshaw obviously he's
telling the truth about the baby
phenomena story because that's the true
stories you can't buy something that
doesn't exist right like there's no
buying there's no buying a formula that
you can't manufacture and money isn't
going to make it manufacture even more
because he goes on in this clip which
I'm not gonna play he goes on in this
clip to continue to talk about how the
reason why we have a formula shortage is
because it's a supply chain because
there's a factory shut down and the FDA
has to get this Factory back running
like that's the whole point
and Dan Crenshaw I think Dan Crenshaw is
making a very uh a very
good political calculation here that the
country is not going to be backing Putin
and they're not going to be backing
politicians that back Putin do you agree
with that do you think and that's why
Tucker's pissed at him and that's why he
has Tulsi gabbard on who is a Russian
asset for all intents and purposes yeah
too sycophant for Putin against Putin's
enemy which is Dan Crenshaw who tells
the truth that he's a murderous [__]
dictator I mean if you're against Putin
you're against Tucker
if you say anything that goes against
what Tucker Carlson is preaching right
if you catch him on the wrong side of
the bed
that wasn't in any window about Madison
cawthorne uh if you catch him on the
wrong side of the bed Tucker Carlson is
gonna come after you because Putin says
you know I'm gonna release my hounds and
obviously Tucker Carlson is you know
Putin TV it is it is Russian TV it is
propaganda so of course he's going to
bring people on like Tulsa gabbard and
and try to push her narrative and her
her propaganda and go against anyone who
says anything that is against what the
show is is trying to to advocate for or
Advocate against whatever it might be
now I will I will say the the nickname
iron patch McCain though
it's a little off for Tucker and the
reason why is because McCain definitely
wasn't a Putin sycophant and and McCain
would be the first one that to tell uh
Tucker to go to [__] hell right and
that and that probably is why Tucker
hates McCain hates Crenshaw now
um he loves Dolce gabbard obviously he's
had her on his show like six times the
last two weeks oh yeah and he's like
yeah you're gonna talk Putin let's talk
Putin I mean do that let's see that who
knows a Putin puppet better than another
Putin puppet right that's true speaking
of weirdos and speaking of weird
Christian people who use religion
you gotta have you seen this so I can
clip Gabe you know Greg Locke is Holy oh
yes guys he's uh he's been banned from
Twitter a couple times and then recently
came back and then I think within less
than 12 hours he was off the platform
again what do you mean like he opened a
new account kind of like Mike Lindell
did uh I forget if he opened a new
account but let me see uh well I'm sure
if I look for him he's I'm gonna he's
opening up Elon Musk soccer cat sock
puppet Russian bot accounts or something
um I am trying to recall exactly what he
had done but I remember that he opened
up an account again and he was like I'm
back and then Twitter was like nope
you're not
well let me tell you before we play this
um Elon Musk won't buy Twitter but in
the fantasy land of the Elon stands
where uh Elon would own Twitter Trump
wouldn't he would decide not to come
back to Twitter but this guy definitely
would be on [__] Twitter and he would
be saying some bio [__] [__] because
you're about to listen to this guy this
guy I thought like Mike Flynn and Mike
Lindell and Sydney Powell and Trump are
[__] wacko dues and Weirdos this
[__] this great lock character
takes the goddamn cake and man does he
use blasphemy on religion uh to to
actually preach Antichrist type [__]
like I'm not I'm not a religion I'm an
atheist yeah yeah so I grew up I grew up
Catholic and that's probably why maybe
I'm an atheist I don't know exactly you
know there's a lot of reasons crazy it's
crazy if you kind of just like question
the church and be like yo this is all
kind of sucks doing this and they're
like shut up right kneel down in the Pew
and pray right be Catholic [__] right
like that's basically
um what happens but this here is just I
mean it's kind of hard to watch I'll
warn the audience but man if you're
looking for some crazy because I had a
lot of people when I post this people
like is this real is this guy [__]
serious or this is this like a movie
what is this
but Greg Locke he seems to be dead
serious and really honestly Gabe I bet
this game has get [__] bodies buried
in his crawl space
this guy has got something going on
there's no way you're saying [__] like
this and you ain't got something going
on somewhere oh yeah you got something
going on let's listen
to Pastor dumb [__] here Greg Locke I'm
to the place right now if you vote
Democrat I don't even want you around
this church you can get out I wouldn't I
I wouldn't even be near near a church
like this and frankly I mean I already
have a problem with this but okay like
we're two seconds into this [__]
thing yeah and we're on he's a he's a
pastor he's a priest right he he's he's
he's a man of God he's a man of Christ
right right a man of Christ okay God
okay you know he's a pastor sorry let me
correct that he's a pastor uh in the
house of House of God he's there to
spread the word of God and why actually
think it's a tent of God because this
guy goes around it is actually a circus
it's actually a circus he does go set up
circumstance and he'd be he performs
these bigoted his like weird diets right
to pull up and spread the tent out and
he's got his little guitars back there
for the Christian band to spread their
HIPAA hypocrisy and their songs but
you've got a guy like this within the
first two seconds we watched he says if
you're Democrat I don't even want you
here right he's the opposite teachings
of Christ
and we're atheists and we know that
let's let's continue with the insanity
you get out you demon
you can get out you baby butchering
election Thief
you cannot be a Christian and vote
Democrat in this nation I don't
I mean it's almost funny I mean it is
kind of funny it is insane especially
when he was like oh man you baby you
baby eating uh election stealing
Democrats like dude have you not looked
at the Republican Party oh my all of
these people week after week there is a
new story about some Republican
candidate or representative or you know
former politician who gets caught with
child porn sex trafficking uh uh you
know being a pedophile you know going to
prison for this like all of these things
not only that I mean there's a ton of
other vile things that they do also just
like stealing and cheating and this and
that
this is the Republican party it's almost
like again you know he's in a house at
this circus he's in a house of mirrors
right now he's looking at himself he's
like you you you you you you you you you
and he's just looking at himself man I I
would imagine that this gay
um definitely definitely has paid for
abortions 100 is paper abortion yeah
yeah yeah without a doubt without a
doubt because he's calling Democrats
butchers he's definitely participated in
some sort of election fraud at some
point and I I still would say and I
don't have any proof of this but I would
say that this guy's got something he's
hiding like you said either either porn
on his Hunter Biden laptop his copy
because they all got a copy of 100
everyone's got a cut everyone got a copy
when they went to their you know monthly
meeting right replacement Theory you
know so I would bet on his thumb drive
that has Hunter Biden's copy of Hunter
Biden's laptop he's probably got some
other [__] on there and he's probably
got bodies buried somewhere
somewhere underneath the tent oh my God
damn man that makes you you get pissed
off if you want to you cannot be a
Christian and vote Democrat in this
nation they are God denying demons that
Butcher Babies and hate this nation
you gotta hand it to him he's got a lot
of enthusiasm though yeah I mean he was
able to spit a lot of lies in that short
amount of time [__] this guy is
committed to this [__] I mean he is
really fully on committed to being not
christ-like it is it is astounding of
how much talent he has to be not
Christian it is I think that I think the
funniest thing there was how uh
Democrats were the America hating group
when it's the Republicans who are the
pro-putin group right which is weird
because you go back to Reagan when it's
like tear down that wall it's like man
how how quickly we have shifted to the
complete opposite of the spectrum or the
Republican party is now pro-putin and
pro-genocide
anti-life that's what they are well
right well I mean they love watching
Putin commit war crimes and killing
innocent women and children you know
butchering children I mean again it's
all the projection I bet if you ask Greg
Locke about Putin oh he'd have all kinds
of wonderful things to say about it yeah
he's a wonderful leader he's a wonderful
man he he really likes Trump and he's a
good Christian probably
was it Locker who's the pastor that said
that we should pray for Putin look at
that [__] up while we're playing the
rest of this crazy [__] day tribe
here
they hate this nation
get mad all you want to I don't care if
you staying I don't care if you throw
tomatoes praise God I'm about to throw a
microphone up in his house
so Trump's scared of tomatoes but
griglock not scared no I'm scared not
scared of tomatoes oh you can eat my
dirty stuff you cannot be a Democrat and
a Christian you cannot somebody say amen
he really he really keeps focusing on
that
Greg Locke seems like he's possessed
like if there ever was the devil you
know and he came back and he's like I'm
gonna take over a body and the body I
chose is Greg Locke and this is it I'm
going to push this which is funny
because he's just promote he's like I
thought Democrats were the ones who are
you know satanic and they're the ones
who are eating babies and butchering
them and doing this and doing that and
he's on stage saying how don't do it I'm
like doesn't really add up but he seems
like he's like possessed by a demon like
somebody needs to do an exorcism on Greg
Locke and get whatever [__] [__] show
is brewing inside him out and that's
just doing these people a very very bad
like just disservice
he either needs an exorcism or a
straight jacket one or the other I mean
I looked up who it was it was uh it was
Franklin Graham was the person another
preacher who said we should pray for
Putin oh well you know pray for Putin to
murder innocent women and children
that's what we should be praying for you
know baby butchers hmm okay
the rest of you get out
get out
get out in the name of Jesus get out in
the name of Jesus now that that is some
Blast for me he's doing some high knees
there he's like get out in the name of
Jesus is that the demon like trying to
get I think I think that was that was
the that was the deal he's trying to
keep it in I don't know maybe or here's
another theory Greg Locke actually took
a demon against their own will just put
him inside and that Demon's like I gotta
get the [__] out of here
this demon is freaked the [__] out by
Greg Locke he's like what kind of host
body is this [__] Earthen vessel get
the [__] out of here
oh my God this [__] guy
I ain't playing your stupid games
a bunch of devils
I'm sick of it
they won't talk about the insurrection
now this is where this is where it goes
from absolute batshit crazy like nuttier
than [__] squirrel turds to dangerous
this is the language that that the Maga
King Mass shooter this is the type of
language that Tucker Carlson is
parroting JD Vance is parroting Trump is
parroting because they're saying that
people are saying Mike Flynn is
parroting these messages that his
[__] Nazi rallies and Nick Fuentes is
parroting this language Marjorie tether
green Matt Getz Jim Jordan members of
Congress are parroting this language
listen to the dangerous [__] talk he
says and how he uses Jesus to justify
his dangerous dog
let me tell you something
you ain't seen the Insurrection yet is
he talking to me he's pointing to me
he's yeah I'm like yeah he's like he's
he's pointing me who is he talking to I
don't know like I heard a guy in the
crowd say something and he's like you
ain't seen the Insurrection yeah boy
yeah let's let's see let's see what what
this
they won't talk about the insurrection
um
he's like he's like Josh Hawley when he
opens up Pornhub he's like is that the
sound Holly man I think Josh Holly makes
he like gets out that grunt like
um moan he's like
that's what he does
I don't know I don't know but he really
he Insurrection sandwich
let's listen
let me tell you something yeah you ain't
seen the Insurrection yet no we watched
it we watched it you keep on pushing our
buttons you low down sorry compromisers
you God hating communist America you'll
find out what an Insurrection is because
we ain't playing your garbage we ain't
playing your mess my Bible says that the
Church of the Living God is an
institution that the Gates of Hell shall
not Prevail against him and the Bible
says that we'll take it by four hours
that's what the Bible says that's what
the Bible says
foreign
and he's using the Bible because his
Bible says his Bible says that he has to
you have to go create and commit
insurrections and kill the devil demon
Democrats apparently this isn't in the
Bible people wonder how we get homegrown
Terry White home-grown terrorists you
got to look at people like Greg Locke
Tucker Carlson Donald Trump
maybe that's who JD Vance thought he was
talking about he was like there are
three people that always get thrown into
the mix it's Donald Trump Tucker Carlson
and he heard Greg Locke all right
JD Vance he's like they're talking about
me JD Vance when they're really talking
about people like [__] crazy like
Greg Locke who's possessed by a demon
that the demon doesn't even want to be
in greglock the whole time the Demon's
trying to get the [__] out of there he's
like how the [__] did I get here what
kind of punishment was this
well it's it's insanity but it reminds
me of a video we watched um a while ago
and if I can find it here do you
remember the video we watched on Alex
Jones which is like the demon the devil
we'll suck out your soul and it's coming
for you you dirty demon Democrats
let's go back to the news
like that's the video that it reminds me
of like these people are competing
for the nuttiest squirrel turd that they
possibly can find they can possibly can
be he's one of these religious types
Gabe he's uh he really he he's almost
like the Pied Piper of the incels if
there is such a thing oh yeah I know who
you're going to bring up you know he
claims to be a doctor he's not even he's
he really likes to attract American
incels but he's he's actually Canadian
um and a lot of people you know in the
chat this
um uh he's a clinical psychologist if I
remember correct is that what he calls
himself just like just like uh Rand Paul
is a doctor right right right right
right right well he needs to have his
[__] head checked by someone because
he tweeted this uh let me pull down the
uh the okay I'm gonna pull up a clip uh
talking about something similar okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna comment on this while
you're doing that Dr Jordan B Peterson
and apparently he's left Twitter because
of this because he was just too bullied
I guess or some [__] I don't know he's a
[__] [__] is what he is and it's not
surprising because he said sorry not
beautiful about this uh the newest
the Sports Illustrated Swimsuit Edition
uh uh human knew is the is the model on
the cover she's [__] smoking hot
she's [__] beautiful absolutely
[__] gorgeous if anyone can't see it
here she is [__] beautiful
I mean the guy is [__] jealous right
listen No One's Gonna look at him and
say yeah you know what I want to put him
on the cover of Sports Illustrated
Jordan Peterson is a [__] cuck
he's definitely a cook and she is she's
[__] gorgeous that's why they put her
on the cover yeah of Sports Illustrated
what in the [__] how anyways as if they
made a mistake here he said sorry not
beautiful and no amount of the
authoritarian tolerance is Gonna Change
what the [__] is Eddie I don't even know
what that means does he means that
people are forcing people to say that
this is beauty what are you talking
about you fool how can you not
objectively say that she is absolutely
drop dead gorgeous I don't care like who
you who what your type is or if you if
you were sexually attracted to women or
not Jordan I mean you know it's
questionable but she is absolutely
gorgeous absolutely gorgeous and I said
I said and I think this is where I was
going with this is the ball painting 100
100 says Jordan Peterson Tams his balls
now I haven't been wrong about a lot
Gabe I have not been around wrong about
a lot
um I've been correct a lot lately so
maybe I'm right on this I don't know if
someone wants to take me up on it but um
but I bet 100 I don't know if anyone
would want to look look I you know I
respect you for the uh the the
prediction and claim that you have here
but I don't know if anyone in our in our
group is willing to get that close and
personal to know if Jordan Peterson is
tanning his balls oh so it's so it's
kind of it's kind of like about the
proof thing more than anything is that
what you're saying yeah yeah I just
don't I don't think people will put
themselves through that you know right
you might have to you know you might
have to you might win 100 but then you
have to pay someone a hundred dollars
just to go find the truth just to go
just to look it up speaking of ball
Tanners I almost guarantee this
[__] tances balls too oh I I
would I would probably put a thousand
dollars on this [__] 10 in his
balls have you seen the the pictures of
the dudes like laying out naked with
their holding their feet up in the air
like tanning their tanning their ass
Squatch like they're oh like they're
trying they're trying to like sun reach
their [__] right right well they're
trying to suntan they're their nuts and
their butts the nuts and butts at the
same time nuts and butts I I would
almost bet that there is a time that uh
Joe Rogan is stripped down and tanned
his nuts and butts at the same time
almost guarantee it no no doubt no doubt
about it what's the slip you got for me
here with the balt over here this is a
this is a clip between Joe Rogan and uh
Jordan Peterson and they're talking
about you know Rogan talk well I mean
I'll let the clip speak for itself but
basically they're talking about
um
uh uh pigmentation uh and also oh it's
got skin color like yeah exactly so so
are they talking about tanning here or
is it just like racist type [__] no it's
just like racist oh okay yeah but it's
tan and it's like oh dark tan black
white like that whole spectrum of like
what shade you are is disgust here and
Jordan Peterson's response is [__]
top oh I bet it's racist as [__] Janie
says tanning their taints they are we're
gonna watch two tank Tanners talking
about other people's
pigmentation apparently I think I've
seen this clip before but you know
Jordan Peterson is a regular on Joe
Rogan's podcast because his audience is
Jordan Peterson's audience like it is
the cockiest of the cuts is the Joe
Rogan's ability to have someone on as a
guest right and then immediately the
next days be like yep so this is what I
believe and I have this person on who is
an expert right and now I believe
everything anyone can say they're an
expert and Joe Rogan is the ultimate
prime example
of the dunning-kruger effect right right
the Facebook Ivermectin group believing
it full stop just because you just read
it right let's listen to the clip
depending on who you ask either you're a
voice of reason and rationality and
and uh you know a personal
responsibility oh [__] this guy's gonna
talk about reasonability and rationale
and oh my God
[Music]
or you're a voice of intolerance and
bigotry and anger and hateful sexual
oppression what did Michael Prejudice
Dyson call you and meaning every white
man yeah and and a mean angry white man
hilarious uh so they're talking about
the Eric Dyson there um he's a professor
I believe
um he's a he's a he's a black guy
obviously um that's why they're upset
that a black dude would call them how
dare you how dare you call me racist
when I say racist things you son of a
[__] let's listen and by the way I want
to point out
um
it really is not surprising that this
the guy who's saying that she isn't
beautiful you dumb look at this [__]
yeah look at this [__] Crypt Keeper
type [__] in a bow tie and it
ain't surprising that he's on the same
Spectrum as Tucker Carlson he's bow tie
wearing [__] not the I'm not
discriminating against bow tie wears it
just seems that there's a pattern here
let's listen
yeah yeah and I mean at all that's
what's dumb about that statement it's
you're not mean at all I am white he's
racist you're just not mean what the
[__]
like literally Joe Rogan is like look
that that where he called you a mean
bigoted racist you're not mean yeah I
mean of course your race is bigot but
you're not mean about it right you're
like white racist and bigoted you're not
or like right white mean and bigoted
you're not you're not mean
there's only one can be true right or
rather one can be false it's like two
truths and a lie you know how dare he
call you mean that son of a [__] what
an [__] called you mean you're not
mean I mean you're a [__] bigot and
we're about to find out how bigoted you
are right actually that's a lie too I'm
kind of tan and he was actually not
black
because I'm I'm darker than you yeah
that's ridiculous yeah but okay so go go
back go back and and hear what he says
let's listen to it again actually that's
a lie too I'm kind of tan and he was
actually not he was sort of brown
he was sort of brown so Jordan Peterson
is trying to make the argument and so is
Joe Rogan that black is is like is like
black like my hat right on my shirt
right exactly not an indication of like
oh that is your race your black white
whatever they're trying to say well he's
actually like light brown he's not
actually black and then they're going to
go into the whole thing about how like
like what is what is black why do they
call them black you know like it's
wait wait you're telling me you're
telling me they're not only going to be
racist they're going to be mean to about
it right babe you're not mean they're
not then you've got Jordan Peterson over
here who is probably whiter than the
goddamn t-shirt he's wearing in his
wannabe 80s tux right now and he's gonna
try and say that some black man is not
actually black and he's not actually
white homie I could probably see through
you you're a [__] ghost you're that
white [__] this is ridiculous that this
guy says he it you know the most I mean
he's gonna say some racist bigoted [__]
here but the most ridiculous thing I
think he said so far is that he's tan
he's like I'm not actually white he's
like actually that's a lie too I'm not
actually white I'm tan and then Jordan
goes yeah and I'm I'm darker than you
what what's up with this right like what
what you're seeing is not real what
you're saying is not maybe maybe this is
just more proof that I'm right that he
Tans his balls because maybe he's
talking about his balls or team because
we all know that these cucks only tan
their balls right right be manly so
maybe that's it maybe that's it I don't
know
because I'm I'm darker than you yeah
that's ridiculous yeah but neither of us
are white well I'm Italian and he was
brown not black well isn't that weird
yeah it's really weird black and white
thing is so strange because the shades
are salmon and brown there's such a
spectrum of shades of people unless
you're talking to someone who is like
100 African from the darkest place where
they're not wearing any clothes all day
and they've developed all that melanin
to protect them what what the [__] is he
talking about
what what is he taught like only people
from uh the darkest place where they
don't wear clothes is the per what the
[__] is he talking about yeah he's like
only a real black person is someone in
Africa who is totally exposed to the sun
everyone else yeah they're brown yeah
they're not black and you and I we're
not white We're Brown
Cynthia points not a good point here oh
my God is this parody no they're they're
talking like seriously yeah this is them
actually having a conversation trying to
make themselves seem relevant by saying
how they're actually not the white guys
right they're not actually racist
they're not white they're not white and
by the way how dare anyone
anyone insinuate that they're mean that
is ridiculous that is that is if they're
going to be offended by anything it's
that you said they were mean and that's
not fair Jordan Peterson let's let's
finish the [__] bigoted launch here
because we know the Dismount is bigoted
as [__] themselves from the Sun you know
it's even the term black is weird it's a
it's a and when you use it for people
that are literally my color it becomes
very strange yeah yeah you know this is
true it's slow so you were asking me but
when you use it for people that are my
color again again he's calling
a white person like Joe Rogan black I
why well what he's saying what he's
saying is if there's light-skinned black
people they're not black right they're
not black if you're light-skinned you're
not black you're not black it's this you
know
oh my God it just it never stops with
these [__] so that's Jordan
Peterson yeah yeah and it is no wonder
so according to Jordan Peterson he's not
actually White
and it's not definitely not mean he's
definitely not mean but he's definitely
he'd never addressed the racist part the
bigoted part I mean why would he why why
wouldn't you don't have to address it
when you just double down on it right
right absolutely absolutely well and
Jordan Peterson not only is he is he a
[__] bonehead and he's an incel and
he's a racist bigot but it's not
surprising he's super religious like he
uses religion and he said he he does
these really weird diatribes where he
says all these really big words to
impress uh and sell white dudes but he
says nothing he seems like absolutely
nothing that sounds a lot like uh Ben
Shapiro yeah you know it it is funny how
Charlie Kirk Ben Shapiro Jordan Peterson
and some of these others are like the
pied Pipers of alpha Cooks it really an
Enzo alplacocks it really is funny how
all that that Venn diagram just seems to
be a [__] Circle weird just a [__]
Circle
of course they do because they're
pro-starvers they're not pro-lifers they
don't like women they hate women they
hate babies they hate children
especially poor children who have to
have WIC who need snap who need food
stamps they [__] hate America they
[__] hate it there's a recall on baby
formula there's a factory shut down the
FDA is working to get the factory back
open so that the formula is safe for
parents to give to their babies got it
the gqp nincompoop let's go Brandon
Nazis have been blaming Joe Biden
personally for the shortage last night
when they had the chance to make sure
that our government could do something
like they've been calling for
192 of them that's right
192 not five not three not a couple
192 voted for your baby to starve your
child your grandchild that neighbor down
the street the person who lives in the
couple floors above you voted for their
baby to starve I'm sure it's because of
radical socialism radical social I mean
we want the government to make sure we
want Joe Biden and the government to
make sure that all babies have food in
this country but when it comes time for
us to actually govern and do policy and
make sure that the Administration has
the relief funds to do what they can do
to make sure that all babies have their
formula [__] you we don't actually
believe in this stuff that's what the
gqp is about you think these Trump
humping idiots who think JFK Jr is still
alive who think he's going to be the
vice president or is the president or
some [__] you think these people are
gonna believe facts no [__] no they're
not that's what that's what the
Republicans are counting on they're
counting on this these [__] imbeciles
to believe they're untruths their
misinformation their disinformation that
is the plan folks and the only way to
combat it is to use the ballot you you
pro-democracy voter I'm talking to you
your ballot is the weapon we can use to
stop this [__] dumbing down of
America the simple fact that we have a
shortage of baby formula in this country
and we we can't even we can't even agree
that babies shouldn't starve no matter
what their color no matter where they
are no matter if they're citizens or
they're not or they're migrants we can't
even [__] agree at this point because
of the dumbing of America that babies
who are in our country should not starve
the best news is is we have a democratic
House of Representatives we have a
senate that is controlled by the
Democrats we have a Democratic president
do you think that if the Republicans
controlled the house they would pass any
relief for baby formula [__] no they'd
be yelling and screaming about it on all
their Trader TV cable news networks and
then not doing a goddamn thing because
that's what they are they're [__] do
nothings they're obstructionists they're
insurrectionist they're fascist let's go
Brandon Nazis 192 Republicans voting to
starve [__] infants oh well it's got
this in the bill and we just can't
stomach we just can't stomach poor
children getting nutrition in this
country my God we're gonna Force women
to have those babies but those babies
should pull themselves up by their
[__] bootstraps and get their own
goddamn formula because Joe Biden let's
go Brandon Nazis the gqp are pro
starvation after days and days and days
and days and days of telling us how it's
the Democrats fault that there's a
formula shortage and Joe Biden should do
something about it right now I don't
even need to show you the [__] proof
I don't have to go through the tweets
Marjorie Taylor green Lauren bobert
Louis Gomer every last one of these
[__] fascist Mac gets all of them
every [__] last one of them had a
tweet or some kind of statement about
how Joe Biden's making sure baby formula
doesn't get into infant's mouths and the
minute they have the chance to actually
govern to do something they vote no [__]
you but they've always voted no they
date deep couple food stamps from the
[__] farm bill which is the [__]
point of the goddamn farm bill that's
been the success of the farm bill for
the last century so if you want to doubt
me that they're pro-starvers good luck
good luck to you you've been listening
to the Tony Michaels podcast in your
face commentary of current events and
political news no rules No Boundaries I
think we've made that perfectly clear we
hope you enjoyed the show and we'll be
back soon in the meantime follow toning
on social media at the Tony Michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[__] em [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon